alors bonjour jean marc jancovici merci
beaucoup de nous accorder un peu de
temps pour parler de 5 g et de sobriété
numérique
donc vous êtes ingénieur consultant en
énergie vous avez une foule d'activités
enseignant écrivain et vous avez
notamment fondé le think tank de shift
project temps de penser de trouver des
solutions pour décarbonés nos sociétés
c'est à dire leur trouver un régime sans
énergie fossile début 2020 vous avez
signé aussi une tribune dans le monde
qui s'intitulait la 5g est elle vraiment
utile donc première question jean marc
jancovici est ce que vous vous diriez
que vous êtes profondément anti 5 g ou
alors vous êtes plutôt de ceux qui
souhaitent attendre afin de mieux
étudier tous les effets de la 5g que ce
soit sur le plan sanitaire ou
énergétiques
il ya un philosophe je me rappelle plus
lequel qui a dit une fois tout ce que
nous pouvons nous le ferons et on est
avec la 5g un peu comme des gamins c'est
à dire que c'est une manière générale on
est que le progrès technique un peu gâté
un peu comme des gamins que d'abord on
sait qu'on peut faire un gadget on le
fait et puis ensuite après coup en diva
tient est-ce qu'on a eu raison de le
faire est vraiment si on n'aurait pas pu
faire autre chose ou est ce que banques
alors la 5g pour moi c'est exactement
comme ça c'est à dire qu on est parti
dans une course au toujours plus donc on
était capable de transmettre tel flux
d'informations dans ton se fait plus
endettés capable d'avoir telle
définition et on ne se pose qu'après
coup la question de savoir si c'est
fondamental pour notre bonheur
et alors cette question elle peut
paraître anecdotique dans un monde dans
lequel on peut faire ça et d'autres
choses en même temps donc dans un monde
dans lequel l'univers de choix augmente
finalement faire ça et autres choses pas
très grave les gens choisiront ceux qui
préféreront est ce qu'on prend vie 5g et
qui préfère les faire de la randonnée à
pau et marron faire de la randonnée un
projet voilà c'est pas le sujet mais
malheureusement le monde vers lequel on
se dirige est un monde de contraintes
c'est à dire que c'est pour prendre un
parallèle monétaire c'est un peu comme
si vous devez gérer une entreprise non
pas avec de plus en plus mais de moins
en moins de clients
comprenez bien que dans ce genre de
contexte pas très sympathiques ou devant
les choix que vous faites alors là pour
le coup pression si vous n'avez pas le
droit de faire et c'est l'erreur 25 fois
il faut vraiment qu à choisir du premier
est en fait mon opinion sur l'a5 j ai
s'inscrit bien dans ce cadre là c'est à
dire que je suis pas pro ou anti 5g j'ai
envie de dire par philosophie je suis
pas en train de dire 'voilà technique
est toujours bonne voie il faut bovese
ou souvent cessé de grands lacs on
oppose
moi je suis en train de dire dans un
contexte dans lequel qui est celui dans
lequel nous sommes qui est celui d'une
course contre la montre a moyens limités
pour essayer de pas tous nous faire
joyeusement sauter en l'air 1,8
milliards sur la planète
est ce que dans les priorités le
développement de la 5g fait partie des
priorités et alors là ma réponse est non
c'est à cette question là je réponds bah
ça c'est la question de la consommation
d'énergie et finalement lié à la halle à
5 g km quand vous regardez ce qui est
lié à la 5g en fait il ya eu toute
petite partie qui est la consommation
d'énergie des terminaux qu'on va
utiliser les régions qu'on va utiliser
mais le gros de la consommation
d'énergie est ailleurs
il est dans la fabrication des
smartphones et des écrans connectés de
toutes sortes
on va utiliser avec la 5g il est dans la
fabrication des objets connectés puisque
vous avez la 5g c'est le rêve des objets
connectés donc on va connecter votre
trousse à maquillage ou pantoufles et
mousseline est ce que c'est vraiment
utile de faire tout sera bon bout de
temps sur donc sa fabrique et tout ça va
également demander de l'énergie vous
avez également les réseaux sur lesquels
il va falloir investir parce que les
flux de données il va devoir augmenter
la fabrication de ces composants de
vente de l'énergie et il va falloir
éditeurs même les opérateurs disent
toujours oui mais la 5g va consommer
moins d'énergie on va pouvoir
transporter trois fois plus de données
que la kadji aujourd'hui avec la même
niveau énergie si l'éternel débat entre
l'efficacité unitaire et la consommation
globale
si vous regardez les voitures qui est un
objet que beaucoup de nos
téléspectateurs connaissent bien les
gens qui vont regarder connaissent bien
les voitures aujourd'hui sont plus
efficaces par kilo quoi tu sais à quoi
vous regardez à une voiture qui pèse
aujourd'hui une tonne et demie la
consommation par tonne de voitures
beaucoup plus basse que celle de la 2
jouant dans laquelle j'ai appris à
conduire mais la consommation globale de
la voiture a pas du tout baissé et le
nombre global de voitures a
considérablement augmenté
donc on a à la fois gagner en
consommation marquent notre voiture est
considérablement augmenter la
consommation du parc de voitures avec le
numérique c'est exactement pareil c'est
à dire qu'en fait les opérateurs vous
font des réponses de jésuites
quand on dit de ce côté ci du lac léman
c'est à dire que la consommation globale
du système
elle augmente et elle augmente même très
très vite ce qu'on a trouvé aux chiffres
projet quand on s'est penché sur la
question il ya deux ans avec les
premiers rapports qu'on a sorti sur la
question c'est que les émissions la
consommation d'énergie par don de
l'ensemble du système digital mondiale
qui comprend à la fois la fabrication
comme je le disais tout à l'heure des
ordinateurs des serveurs des smartphones
des écrans connectés de toute nature et
la consommation électrique annuelle de 7
dispositif est bien l'ensemble de tout
ça c'est 4 % des émissions mondiales de
gaz à effet de serre en 2018 on va dire
c'est à dire l'équivalent de la fois
candide le camion et ça augmente de 10%
par an quasiment c'est à dire qu'en cinq
ans ça représentera l'équivalent de la
flotte mondiale de voitures
donc quand les opérateurs télécoms vous
dise oui on est plus en plus efficaces
c'est un pur mensonge la vérité c'est
qu'ils sont plus efficaces par octets
mais que l'augmentation des cocktails il
transporte et l'augmentation des
appareils de toute nature pour gérer ces
hôtels a beaucoup plus vite que
l'efficacité unitaire effectivement vous
disais à la consommation donc d'énergie
ne cesse d'augmenter aussi le
les données mobiles ont explosé je crois
que c'est l'âge ont été multiplié par 40
depuis 2013
comment vous comptez quand même
convaincre ces jeunes qui utilisent à
fond le streaming la vidéo en ligne
finalement d'aller vers une certaine
sobriété numérique vous même qui avez
cent mille abonnés sur votre chaîne
youtube d'ailleurs alors le la manière
dont on essaye dont on peut les
convaincre elle est de nature d'abord il
ya le premier élément de la sobriété
numérique c'est au moment où on achète
des appareils l'ordinateur que je suis
en train d'utiliser pour vous parler là
malheureusement j'ai dû en racheter un
parce que le précédent est tombé en
panne et j'adore vraiment le dernier
moment pour changer d'ordinateur qui a
duré six ans on peut tu restes essayer
de faire en sorte que les ordinateurs
soient plus modulaire est en travaux que
j'ai remplacé l'ordinateur parce que
juste un petit pont qui tombe en panne
ce qu'on fait trop souvent aujourd'hui
donc il y avait là il ya un aspect qui
concerne pas les jeunes mais qui
concerne l'industrie et au niveau du
consommateur il faut arriver à se faire
une raison en essayant d'espacé le plus
possible ses achats en gros de remplacer
un matériel qui tombe en panne et
surtout de ne pas céder aux sirènes des
opérateurs qui vous disent remplacer
votre smartphone parce que vous y avez
droit
enfin parce que vous en avez le droit il
faut essayer de prendre des appareils
qui sont pas gros c'est à dire ne pas
prendre trop de mémoire de pas prendre
des diagonales d'écran trop grande
de plus petit bah oui mais du coup vous
aurez pas la vidéo du chat de la voisine
en train d'essayer d'attraper une pelote
c'est pas très grave là aussi on y est
on y est on y survit dont on a un vrai
sujet depuis il faut qu'on arrive à
prendre on fait donc moi j'ai envie de
dire ce que j'essaye de faire c'est
faire en sorte que les gens comprennent
ce qu'ils font en espérant que cela
suscitera quand même l'envié de ne pas
faire trop de bêtises trop vite et puis
la responsabilité n'est pas que du côté
du consommateur il est évident que les
jeunes quand ils ont 15 enfin je veux
dire moi des enfants de 15 ans j'en ai
eu considère pas que c'était à lui de
terminer il ya des tables il ya des tas
de domaines dans lesquels effectivement
ils sont déjà capables d'avoir des
raisonnement sophistiqué
il ya d'autres domaines dans lesquels
quand on a 15 ans on n'est pas capable
de voir le vivent 80 40 30
et donc il ya des domaines dans lesquels
il faut pas leur laisser la
responsabilité à eux il faut que la
collectivité d'après nos politiques
finalement d'imposer
oui après prise à l'économie d'aller
vers - d'obsolescence programmée
exactement et puis violée en ce sens par
exemple gouvernement est en train de
distribuer des fréquences pour la 5g la
5g va envoyer sur des smartphones des
appareils de cette taille data on va
leur envoyer de la vidéo en très haute
définition qui est en termes pratiques
ne changera strictement rien à la
définition de l'image que j'avais
vraiment voir sur cet appareil était de
toute façon entre l'art au delà il
travaux d'élagage qu'at il fait pas la
différence parce que l'écran est trop
petit et on va pas se balader tous dans
la rue avec des écrans qui font bien
c'est elle la voilà donc la 5g pour
avoir plus de haute définition sur un
engin comme ça ça sert à rien juste à
rien donc est ce que c'est vraiment
utile d'augmenter les importations parce
que ça s'est pas fait en france est
parfait en suisse est ce que c'est
vraiment utile d'augmenter les
importations d'augmenter de pouvoir des
gaffes à d'augmenter l'empreinte carbone
pour un peu qui sert à rien parce que la
question veut dire quand on répond non
je suis pas sûr qu'on soit donc au final
si on veut avoir peut-être le plus
d'impact c'est plus sûr enfin les
smartphones les ordinateurs qu'on achète
que sur lutter contre le déploiement de
la 5g et de ce flux des échanges de
données
ça dépend à un moment il faut il faut il
faut s'occuper de tout quand on
s'adresse ainsi quand on regarde un
système un système il ya plein de
composantes et donc on est obligé de
s'occuper de toutes les composantes en
même temps on peut on peut pas dire tout
l'effort porte repose là où il faut au
contraire aucun effort ne repose là
c'est toujours un briquet quoi je vais
rien bien garde de tout le monde et
chacun doit faire sa part
si on revient juste un peu sur l'aspect
aussi plus sanitaire de la 5g qui est
vraiment au coeur du débat il ya
beaucoup de craintes autour du
déploiement de ses antennes cinq gms que
justement aussi peut-être le premier
problème c'est pas le smartphone qui est
dans notre poche qui aimait
je n'ai pas autant pas de ta autant mais
qui aimait pas mal de rayonnement et un
petit pose aussi question mais la con
questionne pas depuis des années alors
que tout d'un coup ses antennes 5g pose
un gros problème dans là on sort de mon
domaine de compétence parce que je ne
vais pas regarder pour être très honnête
cet aspect là de très près ce qui est
sûr c'est que le rayonnement
électromagnétique
c'est quelque chose qui quand il est
trop intense peut avoir des effets très
négatifs sur les êtres vivants
vous connaissez le four à micro ondes le
four à micro-ondes c'est un rayonnement
électromagnétique très violent que vous
en voyez sur les aliments efsa les
réchauffe
voilà donc vous doutez bien que si vous
mettez votre cervelle vous aurez du mal
il faut rentrer tout le corps d'enfants
au micro-ondes c'est compliqué mais si
vous mettez votre charge four à
micro-ondes il va pas l'aider alors les
donc les fréquences qu'on utilise sur
les radiotéléphones normalement ne sont
pas du tout à la même intensité et
normalement
l'appareil n'est quand même pas conçu
pour vous accueillir
après ça dépend probablement des degrés
d'exposition donc là je suis totalement
incompétent pour vous répondre
il faut poser la question à des médecins
mais sur la question des fréquences
aussi sur laquelle la 5g va reposer
c'est aussi des nouvelles fréquences par
la 4g des fréquences qui sont qui sont
plus haute des ondes millimétriques
aussi est ce que là vous pouvez nous
expliquer peut-être en deux mots qu'est
ce qu'elles ont différents saison 2 5g
que ça ne la 4g ou d'autres non plus les
ondes sont dites à plus elles sont à
courte longueur d'onde plus elles ont
tendance à être entre guillemets
énergétique pénètrent plus plus
facilement voilà c'est ça la différence
mais je le redis pour savoir exactement
quelles pourraient être les effets ça
dit d'ailleurs c'est pas moi et je vois
les mandéens ça il va demander à mme x
si on revient du coup sûr notre notre
consommation énergétique c'est son
impact sur le climat en 2009 vous
écriviez un livre qui s'intitule s est
maintenant trois ans pour sauver le
monde
là on est onze ans plus tard c'est raté
bah oui pour partie
c'est à dire que les 1,5 degré d'accord
de paris on les a déjà franchi
virtuellement c'est à dire que la
quantité de co2 qu'on a déjà vu dans
l'atmosphère vous garantis que même en
rajoutant rien d'autre il suffit
d'attendre gouvernorat lien avec le
single et les deux degrés on va aller
pour ne pas dépasser les 2 degrés il
faudrait que quasiment sait pas
exactement quel âge vous avez mais d'ici
à ce que vous ayez mon âge il faudrait
que les émissions planétaires soit
divisée par 3 ça veut dire moins 5% par
an ça veut dire un qu'ovide
supplémentaires tous les ans voilà ce
qu'il faudrait pour tenir les deux
degrés pas complètement sûr qu'on va les
tenir
oui oui c'est c'est enfin c'est trop
tard c'est trop tard pour éviter déjà de
très grosses claques à deux degrés par
exemple tous les coraux quasiment tous
les coraux sont ans à 3 5 à 4 degrés
l'été 2003 devient la norme
c'est à dire qu un été sur deux échelons
à ce moment là vous avez des régions
équatoriales dans lesquels plus de 100
jours par an vous ne pouvez pas sortir
dehors parce que les conditions
extérieures sont mortels c'est trop
chaud et trop peu vide pouvait pas être
vous pas transpiré pas évaporée d'eau
toujours dans ces eaux là
la totalité des forêts françaises sont
inflammables et ça lui va lui aussi du
reste sont inflammables comme l'arrière
pays méditerranéen et rien qu'à deux
hommes si on agit maintenant on se
dirige vers ça oui oui même si on
commence à réagir très fortement
maintenant de toute façon les deux
joueurs allaient passer
donc oui oui des cantons expliqué trois
ans était pas évidemment trois ans pour
que le problème se termine c'était trois
ans pour commencer à infléchir les
choses la bonne manière et on n'a pas
fait votre prochain livre lui ce sera
une version
bd j'ai vu avec le dessinateur
christophe blain pourquoi vous avez
choisi ce médium est ce qu'on vous dit
deux mots de ça pour conclure alors
c'est pas moi qui ai choisi de médias
ces médiums qui va choisit donc il se
trouve que j'ai rencontré christophe
blain par l'intermédiaire de son frère
qui était avec qui j'avais des
discussions professionnelles puis qui
m'a dit un jour
tiens au fait j'ai un frère qui fait de
la bd et qui seraient intéressés par
discuter bien volontiers aller en fait
j'ai découvert que c'était le christophe
blain temps je connaissais bien sûr le
travail
et puis il m'a dit j'ai très envie de
faire une belle et là dessus j'ai bien
marrant je suis ravie avec plaisir donc
du coup on pourra apprendre le but du
gloss exactement donc le but du jeu ça
sera d'apprendre quelques allez vas y ça
c'était moins carbone alors sait déjà
que c'est déjà comprendre dans quelle
société on vit
et comprendre le rôle de l'énergie dans
notre société et comprendre
effectivement quelques rudiments sur le
changement climatique tout ça de façon
illustré pédagogique et on l'espère
assez souvent drôle manificat on s'est
rajouté vous lire sous forme d'essai
n'est merci beaucoup jean marc jancovici
pour dans votre temps et à bientôt
peut-être
merci à bientôt merci beaucoup
[Musique]
m